if I may yeah sorry and just a reminder
we are streaming so we wouldn't need to
use the mics just so it picks up on the
streaming that's okay I mean we can hear
each other in the room of course but for
the streaming audience uh so yes um real
quick Mickey Landry most of you have
worked with me in the past a few of you
are new faces so I just wanted to do a
quick introduction there as far as bills
go I think that is incredibly wise to to
have hearings and schedule work sessions
and review those while we're waiting for
the budget as far as uh the public
hearings no more than 30 minutes between
would be fine maybe even 15 minutes or a
couple of the ones that I know we have
one relative just local school budgets
I'd probably be a big or a quick public
carrying the school building Aid ones
would probably be longer and then based
on those public hearings and the
testimony and the issues that are
brought forward we'll probably let you
know how many work sessions that you
would need if you could get it done in
one work session or you would need
multiple
um
I don't have a bill list in front of me
but I think there was at least two
School building Aid related bills three
yeah I mean you'll get a lot of repeat
testimony between those so it might be
the chair could try to consolidate
testimony so those three bills you know
if you stack them as far as when they're
scheduled you could because it's the
same policy just different dollar
yeah if you I mean I'm not sure if it's
permissible to schedule the same build
the same exact time but the chair could
just direct those testifying that if you
you know your testimony for these three
bills will be kind of considered so they
don't say the same testimony three times
that day which should shorten the
overall hearing lengths
yeah you I would give at least an hour
for those three combined you know so
maybe schedule you know 10 10 30 11
something like that and then hopefully
by after an hour or so all the tests
uh so I I see three I see three bills
here that are for school building a one
is 332 and that's representative Cahill
and one is
541 that's representative Wallner
and 546 which is representative Ladd
jeez I don't see any of those going fast
yeah the the the issue of school
building Aid will certainly get a lot of
testimony those three bills if I recall
do have quite a bit of overlap so there
wouldn't really really be different
testimony for each bill and of course
School building will be something that
would be considered as part of your
budget package I with almost I would
almost be certain that the governor's
recommended budget will come up with a
another policy proposal for school
building Aid so what would likely happen
is those three bills would either be
itl'd or retained whatever the committee
wants to do and then whatever the this
division's position on school building a
would be would be incorporating the
house bill one and two so you could
really dispose of these bills real early
knowing you're going to take care of
school building Aid in the budget
yeah you could retain that would mean
you'd have to meet on them in the summer
or you could I yeah
correct yep yeah and you have since
they're not going to another committee
you have technically until crossover to
deal with them but um yeah those would
most certainly be a probably end up
being in House Bill too whatever this
division's policy is set on we would do
a house bill to Amendment
I think you've got
correct
kids it's more of a follow-up on the 129
question I I thought that we were pretty
much set with the school building stuff
and we could bring up 129 or am I too
early
one more question before it
um do all of these bills need to have a
public hearing or have they already had
they had okay they certainly need a
public hearing and those are I think
what representative Emrick is looking to
schedule now and try to figure out how
much time to a lot for each one thank
you
you're my man
um during the last session we used to
hear all the bills together
um for the hearing so that everyone in
the finance committee will we do the
same thing or will we have a unique
division two hearing
I expect we're still doing full Finance
public hearings for the bills when
they're first referred that would be new
to just do a division two hearing I just
talked to Ken and I said I'm going to
schedule some of these for next week and
he said okay
so uh
I'm kind of lost right now I think I
think we'd want to just confirm with the
chair generally bills when they first
come to the committee and need a hearing
it's a full Finance public hearing and
then we'll be referred to the division
for work sessions yeah we wouldn't have
a public input session here necessarily
it would be up to the chair to allow for
public input but the public opportunity
would be in the full committee why don't
I go find out from the chart okay
so um the bills
bills that um
had a had a hearing in another committee
they don't have to have the a hearing in
front of the full committee they just
come to a division correct for so if a
bill was heard in a public hearing and a
another committee and referred here as a
second Committee of Public hearings not
required okay um the only other time a
public hearing would be required if
there was a non-germain Amendment
something new to that bill but that
would be up to the discretion of the
house Clerk and the chair I believe okay
that would that's nothing we would worry
about at least for several weeks right
right the non-jamin period
when the Niger main bills come in
uh yeah and that's that's something that
came up if you recall two years ago um
when when this division was working on
building Aid we were sitting on
additional education trust fund dollars
and the thought was to expedite those
payments and that's certainly something
that could be discussed this session as
well
it would be good if we could do that
yeah and um you are right that the tail
payments are decreasing uh it's set to
expire completely in 2042 but the uh the
total amount that we have to pay per
year is getting less so essentially that
could uh present opportunity for new
projects
full Finance wheel he'll hear all bills
but if we want to get started on them we
food for thought yeah I like the idea
um I'm just wondering how that will
impact
our discussions having that information
here and then having it with the full
Finance usually we get a sense of full
finance and then come here and have that
information it I just wonder how yeah I
don't have a problem with it I'm really
happy to get especially moving some of
these bills along but how that's going
to impact
foreign I don't have any answer I just
it's going to it'll it'll just be a
we have some time and if you we may not
do it all that way all the time but if
you have some time you want to get
started on the bills then they can come
into the full division
you might want to follow it up with
anything and bring it up to the chair to
say is everybody happy with what we've
done did we learn anything new at the
full thing because of somebody
questioning something else that we
didn't know and if that's the case he
could have a follow-up session but
otherwise whatever whatever the
recommendation you did
we'll have that at the final exec
session but we'll see how it works out
and I think I would be curious
um certainly it's not up to the agencies
but one of the things that I've found is
that we have the present and again I
have no problem taking bills early but
we used to have the presentations over
there which gave us information and
knowledge and you could go home and
spend some time and think about it you
could look at the budget with their
discussion in mind so when we come in
here we were working already at a higher
level than if it were a first Hearing in
here does that make sense it says they
informed our thinking and it gave us
time to go through the budget and focus
on specific things so it did impact our
our conversation here I think gave us a
higher level of discussion
well see how it works out
yes representative B
it looks to me like if
they're going to have to come twice if
we do it this way
they got to come here and then they got
to go there
if we just do it once instead of doing
it twice seems to me to make more sense
unless I'm confused
well they may
but this way here it's guaranteed
they're going to come here first and
then they're going to go there
guaranteed
it's just just my opinion it's two two
here
they're gonna have two hearings
I um
I have a question you know we don't have
the bills what are we going to work on
right now I'm just talk I'm trying to
determine if we're going to go down this
new path
how much time to a lot
to the topics oh you guys have a better
sense of these topics than I do that's
what I'm asking
okay
well let's go down the list and see how
if we can figure out how long they might
take I could really quickly thank you Mr
chair
I think
I'm new here but everything I've heard
is that we're gonna have a massive
crunch later and that affects the
quality of our discussions I would be
very comfortable trying this new
approach seeing whether you know it
results in those types of delays or
whether it helps us be more effective at
our job and God knows if it doesn't work
we can always change the process back
but I think it behooves us to see
whether this is a better way and again
I'm the newest member here so I wouldn't
know maybe that's why I'm more willing
to try this and see how it goes thank
you Ricky
so I'm I'm kind of just hearing this
potential approach for the first time
and um I guess the one thing that I
would just give caution is if if we do
hold work sessions especially on
something like School building Aid on
especially specific to those bills prior
to the public hearing this room will be
full of folks who are going to be
probably looking to testify and I think
that's going to put you Mr chair in a
tough spot because work sessions really
don't have a a guaranteed public input
but you'd be in a spot where you'd have
to say no you can't testify the hearings
at a future time an alternative that
would still help the division get ahead
of its work especially on those School
building it matters because those are
going to be the most complicated of
these initial bills is we could just
invite the Department of Education Amy
Clark their engineer for the school
construction program to come in and just
give a overview of the school building a
program to division two that way when
you do hear the bills you'll be more
equipped to understand the program and
and I think that'll expedite kind of
dealing with those but you won't get
into that public hearing out of order uh
dilemma okay good thought could I add to
that and say maybe we should have the
department of Ed come in
um in terms we have Caitlyn and and
whoever and give an overview of what's
going on at the department and Amy will
give us what her part with the building
Aid and I think that would give us a
good start and give us a deeper
understanding of the content that are in
these bills and the impact that they
will have on budget
okay
it's a good compromise
now that would still require public
notice
it would it would be a public posted
meeting for the Department of Education
presentation essentially so the public
would be able to uh monitor it listen to
it stream it come here if they would
like but it would just be a department
presentation to the committee versus any
three down
four to go
yes thank you in regards to the bill
that we were asking about the 129
providing menstrual hygiene products in
schools the text of the bill requires
that the Department of Education funds
the cost and allows the school districts
to receive funds for also providing this
in previous years so that's the guess to
I think those two other bills aren't
going to be anywhere near the workload
as the school building Aid would be I
think you could almost do those in the
traditional order of public hearing and
then schedule a work session it's still
up to you Mr chair if you wanted to have
a work session prior but I still think
you may have that same dilemma where you
get a lot of folks that'll come into the
work session thinking they can testify
we could have a public hearing on 129.
yeah and then go to a work session
because it's not that big a deal I don't
yeah I think 129 and and uh what's the
other there's a couple of them here so
four 468
um I also don't think would would be
much and then uh 550 no not 55.
um
207 sorry
so 207 uh 129 and
468 to me would be less of a workload
than the three School building a bills
for sure
so if we were going to have a public
hearing on those about how much time
for
uh for 207 and 468 I'd say 15 minutes
between is probably sufficient possibly
30 minutes for House Bill 129 I'm just
so if you did like a 10 10 15 and a 10
30.
so
468 207 and then a half hour for 129
would probably be sufficient
I mean we tried to re-qualify that pool
what was the last one and that was six
would be quite quite a chore
so these are strictly public just the
public hearing okay I got so many notes
207 yeah
and 120 my my pins went out of beans
okay at 10 30.
no I got it thank you
and chances are 129 and 468 will also
become budget items because both would
require if this division supported it
adding something to the budget spending
money to fund the hygiene products or to
fund an attorney to recodify election so
these bills would almost be disposed of
and you're going to put it in House Bill
too similar to school building a so uh
the one 207 that's actually just a local
impact that's not even a state impact
you could if you're good with it which
it looked like I think it was a pretty
benign Bill unless we hear testimony to
a different uh tune you could probably
move that bill along real quick but the
others again you can dispose of the
bills real quick but the subject matter
will be part of the budget talks later
and I track all that for you I'll make
sure that when we get into house bill
one and two we consider these bills if
you've retained them or whatever the
decision was made
so the department of Ed is going to give
us a overview which would incorporate
332 541 and 546.
and then we have 468 207 129 starting at
10 o'clock
and then
how long did the Department of Education
depends on the topics if you stick to
school building Aid I'd say
I'd say I'd keep two hours hour hour to
two possibly
at least an hour
were you looking to do this on the same
day yes okay
um the the public hearings keep in mind
that would be a full committee
thing so that's that's where it gets old
doing division two scheduling versus the
public hearings I think the requirements
yeah
so I think I think it's a a good idea to
try to front load the bills but I I feel
like it creates a little bit of
complications to try to do division work
prior to the public hearings okay
um
and if some of you want to wait till
that might just be within the next week
okay
well I've tried to push the Rope up the
sure I'm gonna try to have a caucus for
the Republicans down in 212. when you
expecting Jason Osborne
okay he wants to come and clock us with
the Republicans
all right thank you thank you
yes
thank you
um as I recall it was I liked you know
Mickey's idea and representative Heath
to have people come in to give us an
overview it really does help it gives
you some context
um
it may not work with the day that you're
scheduling here but it would be possible
also to have Department of
Transportation come in and give us that
pre
um Bill kind of stuff just to get to lay
of the land no real or lay of the road
no pun intended exactly but a way of
giving us an overview of the past year
of Transportation where they want to go
what they've been able to achieve it
becomes more of a narrative in which it
helps you to find context when we
actually get the budget so if there were
time or possibility to have
transportation come in and give us that
overview would be a help I think my
first year on finance that happened for
full financing
Health and Human we did we had you know
well they are meetings with Ways and
Means um often that was joint with
Finance but there was you know we were
invited to the ways and means but then
um we also had that just with finance
and just within our division
um and it's you know you have it's a
smaller context and so you're better
able to ask questions or Focus questions
specific to your section of the budget
so it was very helpful okay
and you're right representative we have
had full committee uh Department
presentations before I'm not sure if
that's the plan again uh it didn't sound
like it no I didn't so I I certainly
think there is value in having some
agencies come in to just talk about kind
of bigger picture stuff not diving into
budgets yet because of course they're
still working on their budget with the
governor's office but at least kind of
give you an agency overview talk about
some of their major programs just so
when you do get the budget it's familiar
so if we have the Department of
Education in at 10 o'clock
invite them in at 10 o'clock next
Tuesday
that
and and I guess the question is do you
want to just stick to uh just School
building Aid because of course the
Department of Education has you know
adequate education I think so they could
talk about any of the bills are coming
before us as part of that presentation
yeah Mary
they may I really think it's important
for them to do an overview of the school
funding I think that's going to be
something that we're going to need to
focus on and inevitably that's building
Aid is going to be part of that so I
think if they could do that they did I
couldn't make the demonstration they did
for the presentation they did for
education but here it was quite good
um and I I think it would benefit all of
us to hear that if it's possible I think
you know we could do two hours in the
morning two hours in the afternoon for
essentially a full day of Department of
Education just talking about their state
aid programs is I think important so
School building Aid adequate education
grants special education Aid even efas
Charter Schools you know all of those
programs education trust fund programs
essentially are important to this
Division I think kind of getting that
refresher for our attorney members in
that crash course for our new members
would be certainly valuable because I
think there's some of those are in the
policy committee right now
yeah certainly so um there's a lot of
bills that could be second referral to
us on on a lot of these issues yeah
yeah and if I can add perhaps you know
three hours for Department of Education
but then also had to have time for
higher education to come in
um you know our community colleges the
university system the technical schools
and get you know even then you've got
three of them so if you get 20-minute
overview of something from the higher
foreign
can I just ask a question about
clarifying what um departments we are
going to cover in division two
um during the last session we picked up
Des
um and I think it was because we had
done our work in um the chair of Finance
was our chair so we just kind of took up
what she had to get done right are we
going to continue no no we'll be go back
to one yeah so we're going to be back to
the traditional agency assignments yeah
uh so last term there was some change in
some leadership and division members got
moved around a little bit so a couple of
the agencies slid over just to kind of
uh spread the workload if you will but
um we're resetting this here was the
plan representative Weiler confirmed
that so okay we're back to our normal
Aid agencies which
um I do have that before you
um
so if you that first page that I sent
you or handed out there you see on the
third column over you see my name at the
header so those are our agencies that
we're responsible for their budgets and
subject matter on bills anything that
comes through Finance would be referred
here
well
then I guess we're down to the
Department of Education
in some form filling up a day
yeah I think certainly uh just just if
nothing else just talking about their
state aid programs could fill a day
having higher education come in uh
invite CSS ccsnh and usnh would be
valuable uh and certainly the Department
of Transportation Department of Safety
has quite a bit too a lot of theirs does
um
fall in line well with the operating
budget presentations we'll hear when
that happens if there's anything
specific that any of the members can
think of that's worthwhile to invite the
department of safety and we could but I
kind of feel like doe and Dot are
probably our biggest hitters to kind of
get a head start on on what they've got
going on
well if we can pull this off for next
Tuesday is that agreeable
because that frees us up in what might
yeah I mean so reminder we don't have
we don't have the budget yet so they're
still working on their budget so it's
really just subject matter presentations
and I'm not I think if you did a doe
presentation on one day and then another
day half D.O.T half higher ed right
you'd be pretty good I think that's a
pretty good uh good effort and if we
still would have two weeks in between if
you feel um because we will have Bill
work I assume sometime in those two
weeks we'll have the bills heard and
we'll can have our work sessions in here
but if we did want to do other uh invite
other agencies in we certainly could do
that too but I think scheduling Tuesday
Wednesday doe Dot and higher ed is a
dude
I thought safety was one of those
they are and we could um I feel like uh
a whole day of D.O.T and safety is
probably too much but a morning of just
Dot and safety is probably not enough if
that makes sense like it's not like I
think two hours for both of them is
probably uh uh pinching them a little
bit on time
um we could maybe do Dot
uh in the morning and then split safety
and higher ed in the afternoon perhaps
um do you know do like a one to four
afternoon perhaps and I think that could
maybe
you know do like an hour for uh
safety an hour for ccsnh an hour for us
on Tuesday we'll be the department of Ed
yeah 10 to 12 and then one to four
Mr chairman are you looking at the 24th
and the 25th is that what you're looking
at yes yeah next Tuesday Wednesday okay
and of course
um all best plans you know if the
agencies are available you know we're
not sure well to connect with them to
see if they can set aside the time for
us
you'll do that
generally Janet does the scheduling but
I can you know just make sure she knows
well I don't know I'm just lucky I got
Mickey is that what you've got
I think if I think if we did uh on the
25th 10 o'clock dot one o'clock safety
uh and then two o'clock CCS three
o'clock usnh or something like that
so you'll coordinate that with Janet
yeah I'll connect with Janet and see if
we can invite the folks see if they're
available and adjust if we need to okay
but
this is just content overview it's not
budget discussion just yeah I mean they
can speak to I don't even think you want
to get too deep into their agency
budgets even I think just hearing about
you know who they are what they do
um that's that would be valuable for the
committee just to get some of that
knowledge down before you start getting
all right
you never know where you end up and then
hopefully uh sometime you know we'll
maybe I'll connect back with
representative Weiler or Janet or just
see what their plan is for full
committee work sessions because the
other divisions I would expect are gonna
want to start working on bills and work
sessions and you know traditionally we
have the public hearings first I think
that would create a little bit of chaos
if we did it out of order okay
um but hopefully if they can't make the
calendar for this week to schedule the
hearings or
that's the other thing too we just need
to make sure representative Wilder is
not scheduling public hearings on the
24th and 25th right now as we're in here
but I don't even sound like it didn't
sound like it so at some point those
will be scheduled and then we can have
our work sessions on those six bills you
know possibly the week of the 30th
traditionally uh this committee how many
a lot yeah it varies on the you know how
we feel about the budget and it varies
on not just these bills but when second
committee bills start coming in it's
impossible I think to predict
oh generally I think the work sessions
though are pretty functional and to the
point we don't drag things out very much
and a lot of things will just get
retained so it's like oh we'll deal with
that after we get the budget right
because a lot of them are heading for
correct right away
it is a lot of first referral bills for
sure
um but like we said we have the time to
do it before February 15th so
um I think we'll be we'll be okay and
and five out of the six of them will end
up in House Bill 2 anyways if the
oh
exciting start well I I just mentioned
that it now that I'm trying to get a
little more of an overview of what you
what you were doing here what you were
trying to do was
traditionally we have come in and had
the Departments come in and give us an
overview before before we even looked at
any bills right so doing that is
actually falling back to what what's
the last term
well I don't think we did it last term
well we did it in here I mean you might
have but I'm talking full financed
because we have yeah we were on Zoom
last time during this phase so it was it
was definitely uh that's why I can't
remember it was business not as usual
but
he's probably doing laundry yeah oh man
I'm getting good at that
okay
so we're comfortable whoever where we
are right now
um
and I would appreciate it if y'all if
you have a card if you or a piece of
paper just give me your your phone
number and your email address to Tom
the one you really use not the one
I don't use the government email address
so I'm one of those
and you're one two well no I I use the
legislative email address that that I
have here fine I I'm just saying I just
want to be able if something comes up I
want to I hope I did that's what's on
which I'm using yeah that's my candidate
card it was before I had a legislative
would you want me to use the legislative
one uh I would probably prefer that you
use the legislative address for
committee business just to keep things
separate but that's my cell phone number
and also okay thank you and by the way
my legislative address is DPM you don't
have to type the full number they gave
and I'll screw that one up
and representative Heath before I reach
out to anybody I would get in touch with
you
my regular emails on the back I use them
both because I'm terrified I'm going to
miss any now uh but
Dr Karma okay good I've been using my
personal one but yeah I will keep
it's mine and this is my great
comcast.net and this is myself okay good
all right you haven't got one
you're working on it Well mine's easy
I don't use I don't use well legislate
legislate one forwards on
and if you if you really want to get
my number is
-793-9055.
that works for me a piece of paper is
yeah
well the reason I explained that at
yourpreter.com because I don't get very
many in there uh hopes I get a lot you
know because it's it falls through this
legislative
because they're all subject to freaking
918. great yeah no reply
right
if it you know you'll hear the the
reason for it from the sponsor of the
public hearing it's certainly something
that uh on its face doesn't look like
it's a big change and it's not something
that's really a charge of
Finance is not a state related impact so
right and and we're talking about 207
it's almost like most municipalities do
that anyway
to accept they have to accept the money
funds to raise their spending levels and
I think I think it goes a threshold of
five thousand to twenty thousand so it
wasn't
you know some smaller districts that's a
big amount of money but
but we'll we'll hear about it
can I um just double check we don't need
public notice or we don't need any
noticing to have agencies come in and
talk to us we can just do that without
any prior they'll be scheduled they'll
be in the calendar but it doesn't have
to be a public notice uh it'll be public
or public notified in the house calendar
it won't be up okay is there time to do
that for next week I'm going to check
with Jan I think we can if we get it in
today Thursday at 5. Wednesday at five
yeah I think today you get in the
calendar today to file okay so they do
have to be noticed somehow okay it's uh
I'll just have to hustle to make sure
the agencies can commit to that too
prior to the posting deadline but we
should be okay
oh
and this is a an aside one of the things
that came up during that whole covert
thing a 91a issue was is you can't if
you're discussing business you can't hit
reply all
because it's a meeting then so we can
hit reply all about the scheduling or
anything else but we can't have content
about something in reply all so anybody
else have anything
nice meeting you all look forward to
working with you have a good weekend and
Shannon Reed at ccsnh had some annual
reports for the system that she was just
going to distribute if if you guys